[Music]
the coronavirus pandemic has also become
an inequality pandemic
never before have we seen such a
simultaneous increase in the gulf
between the haves and the have-nots
around the world the virus has exposed
fed off and increased existing
inequalities of wealth gender and race
hundreds of millions of people are being
forced into poverty while the richest
both individuals and corporations are
getting even richer thanks to soaring
stock prices
the crisis has exposed the inability of
our deeply unequal economy to work for
all
at the same time it's revealed the vital
importance of government action to
protect our health and livelihoods
this is your kovid 19 update i'm chelsea
delaney in berlin
no part of the world has been untouched
by covet 19 but the effects have not
been evenly shared the world's poorest
have been hit especially hard by
lockdown school closures and disruptions
to health care this next report takes us
to the suburbs of calcutta india where
endemic poverty has worsened throughout
the pandemic
for 20 years tobias fogged has been
working with the aid organization german
doctors in the suburbs of kolkata
he's saved countless lives during that
time but now covet 19 has made life here
even tougher than it already was
masks and disinfectant are too costly
for most and it's virtually impossible
to stick to coronavirus health
regulations
in the inner city areas where we work a
typical indian family of seven has
around 10 square meters of living space
that means they already have to sleep on
bunks and in shifts
if on top of that we say now please keep
your distance from each other it would
almost be cynical to demand something
like that
tobias folked knows how tough life can
be for people here
in 2020 india's economic growth dropped
by 23
the coronavirus lockdown had disastrous
effects
an overwhelming majority of the
population are day laborers
according to a study by action aid 80
lost their employment as a result of the
pandemic
here lockdown means starvation
the situation is not that different in
many latin american and african
countries
in early 2021 the international aid
organization oxfam published a study
called the inequality virus
it showed that since march 2020 the
number of people living in poverty has
risen from 200 million to 500 million
on top of this
6 000 to 12 000 people die each day from
starvation
let's
at the end of the day
many governments in the global south
have been forced to make some very
difficult decisions
that's because the knock-on effects of
lockdowns are far more serious for
people there than we in the global north
can really imagine
additionally any improvements made to
providing access to education for
children have been negated by efforts to
curb the pandemic according to unesco
more than 880 million children worldwide
have suffered educational disruptions as
a result of partial or full school
closures
education is the key factor when it
comes to helping people escape poverty
and we now see that as a result of the
pandemic as many as 33 million
school-aged children are not returning
to education
researchers like detlef muleman from the
university of bonn have been collecting
data on coronavirus regulations in
africa
fact is africa is young
people over 65 who are the most at risk
age group make up just four percent of
the population there
that's in contrast to 20 to 25 percent
in the global north
this raises the question as to whether
the tough coronavirus regulations may
end up having far more serious
consequences than the pandemic itself
during the pandemic agriculture and
trade have suffered
prices for staple foods have more than
tripled
farmers were not allowed to sell their
goods at markets
rural medical staff were recalled to the
cities
one observation from a project i'm
involved in in ethiopia
is that the government's actions have
resulted in a disruption of
relationships on two levels
first of all between rural communities
and neighboring small towns and large
cities and the capital
and secondly to a certain extent between
the rural population and state
institutions
former german development minister
gerard muller has said quote far more
people will die from the consequences of
the lockdowns than from the virus itself
we talked to maria flachsbart former
parliamentary state secretary to the
federal minister of economic cooperation
and development
we asked her what long-term damage could
come about from the pandemic
restrictions
the worst consequence of the pandemic
has clearly been hunger
those in informal jobs don't qualify for
government relief spending
nor do they have health insurance
the second direct impact is not only the
effects on health from the coronavirus
itself but rather the interruption to
wider vaccination distribution of all
kinds
for example to vaccination programs
against measles yellow fever and
whooping cough
[Music]
on the african continent alone experts
are predicting an additional 400 000
deaths due to malaria and hiv
along with another half a million deaths
from tuberculosis
although these numbers are very high few
people were paying attention to the
problem of tuberculosis
the same thing is happening in india
where all the focus is on covet 19.
when i started 20 years ago around 500
000 people a year died from tuberculosis
these figures are on the rise again and
yet they are rarely reported on
one side effect of the global fight
against covert 19 has been that the
overall global health situation is
deteriorating
tourism has also largely collapsed
worldwide
25 african countries are on the verge of
national bankruptcy
germany's foreign development minister
called for a 50 billion euro
stabilization program made up of
european loans and emergency aid aid
organizations like oxfam are calling for
an internationally financed global
social security fund
time is of the essence
we need more money and more people to
commit to fighting both the immediate
and long-term consequences of the
pandemic
otherwise it will come back to haunt us
that's because the worse the situation
gets the more people will try to flee
poverty and disease leading to more
migration
without much needed aid the global south
may be set back decades in its
development
but right now industrialized nations are
busy with their own crises
the inequality virus will likely cause
long-term damage around the world
now it's time for you to ask us to
answer here's a viewer question for our
science correspondent derek williams
why are vaccines still not universally
available
many of the experts i've read tend to
talk about two different aspects of this
issue um the first is vaccine shortages
which are caused by
factors rooted mostly in logistics for
instance
um the fact that production of any
medical product is going to be limited
by bottlenecks in upstream feedstocks of
the ingredients that go into it
it simply takes time to ramp up the
entire production chain
of these highly specialized vaccines to
the kinds of scales that we need to
fight a global pandemic
the challenges surrounding vaccine
transport and distribution
also contribute to shortages
but at least the vaccine shortage
problem is theoretically solvable right
i mean we just have to get production up
to speed and we're doing that but
the same can't be said
for other factors that have gotten in
the way of universal availability
they're what the experts mean
when they talk about
vaccine inequities
the program that was supposed to prevent
them
the kovacs initiative has struggled from
the beginning
to meet distribution targets for poorer
countries not only because
the logistics are hard but because
wealthier countries
quickly snapped up nearly all of the
available stocks for their own
populations
according to the who vaccine
manufacturers are currently churning out
around one and a half billion doses of
vaccine every month so the issue
has now become a lot less about
shortages and a lot more about ongoing
lopsided allocation
and that's continuing even though we
know that the fastest way to end the
pandemic
is to make vaccines
universally available
[Music]
now scientists are still learning about
the omicron variant of the coronavirus
but already there is evidence that it
may be evading of existing vaccines also
worrying research indicating that
important therapeutics called monoclonal
antibodies might work poorly or not at
all against the new variant
monoclonal antibodies which are produced
in bioreactors mimic the naturally
occurring antibodies made in the body
after an infection with saskov2
if given to patients while they are
still in the early days of the disease
they can help mitigate the cause of
covet 19 and prevent it from progressing
to a more severe stage at least with
earlier variants they did but the latest
results conclude that in the case of
omicron two of the three monoclonal
antibody treatments regularly used in
the us those manufactured by pharma
giant eli lilly and biotech firm
regeneron would not help prevent serious
illness in lab tests on cells only the
monoclonal antibody therapy made by
gluxosmithkline continued to have a
significant impact on omicron's
replication
thanks for watching